Speaker 1: I'm sure you are all very familiar at
this point with Herschel Walker, who is running
for Senate in Georgia against Raphael Warnock.
And recently there was a sort of scandal where he
made a remark about how this is the context, this
isn't the scandal, but he made a remark about how
a problem in the black community is fathers aren't
staying with their kids and they absolutely,
absolutely need to do that. And it's really a big
problem. And I mean, we can have a discussion,
of course, we want to encourage people to stay
with their kids. Absolutely. That's not really
what this is about. It's more a hypocrisy
angle. And so just to refresh your memory,
let's look at a couple of those moments.
Speaker 3: The family hole is a major, major
problem, even if you believe that one, even if you
have to leave at the moment, you don't leave the
child. Right. Right. You let that child know. You
try to work it out. You've got to be respectful to
her. If you're going to be respectful to other
things, you show it to your child. Herschel
Walker, who was born in Wrightsville, Georgia,
you I took it. I took care of a lot of people
in my hometown. I took care of a lot of the places
around where I grew up. I was being like a father
to some of those kids that it may have have.
Speaker 1: So generally I have no problem,
as I said, with people encouraging, you know,
men to stay in their families and all those
things. Of course, that's absolutely what fathers
should do. But one of the ways that we Republicans
specifically get out of answering for any real
policy prescriptions they have for the country
in regard to these really big problems sometimes
that are more specific to certain communities
is by making it an individual issue. And so
instead of proposing large actions that the
government could take or actions that we should as
a political body, invest in time or energy money,
instead, it's all about that guy, that one and
that one and that one. That one. It's just they
made bad decisions, which on an individual
basis, if that person was my friend. Yeah.
To give them that advice. Hey, stay with
the kids. Right. But on a societal basis,
these big problems that he's trying to address in
answering whatever question he was answering is
something we have to address on a societal, basic
basis. Big trends, big issues that we see broadly
in our country aren't going to be be solved by
someone just saying a bunch of rhetoric and people
are going to hear, stay with your kids and not all
of a sudden all these problems will be solved. No.
If you see broad societal problems, we're going to
have to have broad societal solutions. And those
have to be policies that we can implement. Using
our political power. And so Republicans do a
really good job of getting out, of answering
for what some policies that you would propose
to invest in these communities, uplift them.
Instead, they make it. It's just some bad
dudes. That's the core of all these problems. But
you and I understand specifically, since he was
referring to them, the black community, the way
that we solve any problems that we recognize are
unique to that community is not just
by finger wagging. Right. Again,
you have a friend, you want to give them that
advice. Awesome. Or even you want to encourage
society broadly. Stay with your kids. Love
your kids. Of course you should do that.
But that's not the solution to all of
these problems we have that we need
to. We need to address. And to put a cherry
on top of all of it. Herschel Walker, son,
is very outspoken. He's a conservative and he
put out a video supporting his dad's message
that was a little bit cringe. Others, it would
be great if you stayed home and raised your
kids instead of ran off to bang a bunch of.
Speaker 3: Women who weren't your baby mama.
Stay home and raise your frickin kids. Your kids
need a father. Get back home. Get back home.
If you take out your thing and you get a woman
pregnant. Guess what? The party days are over. The
acting foolish days are over. You go get a frickin
job and you support your new family. Get home.
Speaker 1: Raise your so very in your face. So
that's kind of all the context to the story that
we're talking about today. That would mean a lot,
maybe more, at least coming from someone who is
living the principles that they're espousing, who
is loving and supporting their kids, all of their
kids. But after these statements made by Herschel
Walker, it came out that he had three children
with three separate women who were not previously
disclosed to the public, which for someone as
famous as him, to have kept them unknown for
that long. That's not an accident. And there
is no way he was active in their lives in the
way that he's saying other people should be,
or there would be some public record of that. Some
public record for someone as famous as him. So.
You would think that would upset that type of
hypocrisy, that type of not living your family
values would upset evangelical people. Right.
That's what they they claim to care about. No,
I'm sure your guess that Herschel Walker
received resounding applause from evangelical
Christian activists on Saturday following
revelations he had fathered three children
he had not previously discussed publicly. The
half full room of conference goers at the Faith
and Freedom Coalition's annual gathering in
Nashville went wild for Walker, perhaps the
most high profile Republican Senate candidate this
cycle, running in one of the most contested races.
Even though it is really clear by now that
Republicans don't really care about having
politicians who live the principles they claim
to hold. It still fascinates me every single time
when this, you know, plain examples of hypocrisy
come out and they don't care at all. A very clear
example of this is Trump. Evangelical evangelical
Republicans claimed to care about family values,
and that's what justified them being super
judgmental towards all of these groups who didn't
live the way that they wanted them to live, i.e.
the LGBTQ community. But then Trump comes along,
has a very anti evangelical past,
if you want to say it that way, and
they don't care at all. It's wild. And I think
this is easily one of the reasons that they are
still as successful as they are, because they'll
take anybody as long as you'll say their talking
points, spread their message, act the way that
they want you to act, you're in. It's not about
consistency. It's not authenticity. It's power. If
you can take power and use it towards their ends,
the ends they actually care about, then you're
a part of the club. And the funny thing is,
comparing that to the left is pitiful because
the left, if you step on a bug, you're out.
So we can take a little bit of a lesson from them
and be a little bit more tolerant of people with
not perfect pasts. But generally, I like where
we stand. I'll be following Herschel Walker's
race with Raphael Warnock. That has been very
fascinating so far, but I'll be watching it each
step of the way and covering it on my own show.
You can find that at Luke Beasley on YouTube,
or if you're listening to this as a
podcast, you can search Luke Beasley
on any podcast listening platform to
listen to it. We'll be back with much more.